bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
l'émission dans laquelle on vous
explique
semaine après semaine pourquoi à la fin
vous êtes toujours les dindons de la
farce
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler du coc vides et des inégalités
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de ses caches le virus des inégalités
c'est l'intitulé du nouveau rapport de
l' ong oxfam la crise sanitaire aurait
creusé encore un peu plus les inégalités
entre les plus riches et les plus
pauvres
alors comment le coronavirus at il rendu
les riches plus riches et les pauvres
plus pauvres comment venir à bout de ces
inégalités on va en parler dans cette
émission et pour cela nous rejoindront
en deuxième partie l'économiste philippe
maurer
comme chaque année à la veille du forum
de davos loi angie oxfam publie son
rapport sur les inégalités dans le monde
sans surprise le coronavirus cet invité
cette année dans ce document l' ong y
révèle que les 1000 personnes les plus
riches du monde ont retrouvé leur niveau
de richesse d'avant la pandémie en
seulement neuf mois et ce alors que des
millions de personnes pourraient se voir
basculer dans la pauvreté ces dix
prochaines années
explications avec le tiroir cage
d'antoine bassesse 2021
la crise du coc vide a plongé l'économie
dans la détresse pas
chômage monte et les populations du
globe perdent tout du pouvoir d'achat
tout
non car un petit groupe de riches
résiste encore et toujours à la
précarité
c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirme le
rapport de oxfam sur les inégalités et
le co vide qui est sorti il ya quelques
semaines un vrai brûlot qui dresse un
constat alarmant sur les effets de la
crise actuelle
depuis mars et l'apparition du coc vide
les 10 hommes les plus riches du monde
aurait engrangé près de 540 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires
largement de quoi mettre en place un bon
plan de relance ou le méga campagne de
vaccination dans le monde entier
pour ce qui est des français ils ont
engrangé 175 milliards entre mars et
décembre dépassant leurs niveaux d'avant
crise comme si rien ne s'était passé
cocorico du coup non bah pas vraiment
parce que de l'autre côté du miroir
selon oxfam
la crise du coc viderait fait basculer
près de 1 million de français
supplémentaires dans la pauvreté
le nombre de bénéficiaires de l'aide
alimentaire atteignait en automne 2020
lui
millions de personnes contre 5 5
millions l'année précédente
il en est de même pour le nombre de
bénéficiaires du rsa qui auraient bondi
de 8,5 pour cent par rapport à l'automne
2010 neuf et ça touche aussi les par
anja puisque les 20 % des français les
plus pauvres ont vu leur épargne diminué
de près de 2 milliards d'euros pendant
le premier confinement à leurs cous %
des français les plus riches
voyez pourri leur fortune augmenter de
plus de 25 milliards d'euros
des chiffres qui ne risque pas de
s'arranger quand on sait que sur le
fameux plan de relance du gouvernement à
100 milliards à peine 1% est consacrée à
la lutte contre la pauvreté
olivier près de 540 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires depuis mars pour les 10
hommes les plus riches du monde
alors que le virus est appauvri à de
nombreuses personnes ont sans doute un
peu mais comment expliquer concrètement
que à les plus aisés ont pu non
seulement à tirer leur épingle du jeu
mais aussi s'enrichir alors c'est pas le
virus le virus il a rien à voir là
dedans il a eu un effet accélérateur et
il a eu un effet seulement
d'accélération le le problème il est
bien en amont il est depuis que les
banques centrales impriment de l'argent
et quand elles impriment de l'argent en
fait ça ne va pas dans l'économie réelle
ça va juste sur les marchés financiers
ont les plus grosses fortunes
elles sont grosses fortunes parce que
elles détiennent les parts de leur
société monsieur et le musk est passé en
quelques en quelques mois à la position
de 1ère fortune au monde comment tout
simplement parce que le titre tesla a
monté et pourquoi le titre tesla a monté
simplement parce que on met des
liquidités dans les marchés financiers
et donc ses liquidités vont s'investir
sur des actions en priorité est donc
qu'est ce que ça fait ça fait que dans
l'économie réelle dans l'économie réelle
vous avez
dd une baisse de l'économie réelle un
effondrement même de l'économie réelle
en 2020 et qui sera probablement suivie
en tout cas sur la plus grande partie de
2021 et donc vous avez des gens qui sont
de plus en plus pauvres mais ça n'est
pas le virus le virus a simplement
accéléré les choses au niveau des
liquidités qu'on a mis sur le marché
pour empêcher les marchés de baisser et
donc les les très riches en ont profité
la classe moyenne s'est fait laminer et
va continuer à se faire laminer et
ensuite les pauvres sont devenues de
plus en plus peau merci olivier on passe
tout de suite à la deuxième partie de
cette émission
et cette semaine pour parler des
inégalités qui se creusent un peu plus
chaque jour nous sommes en liaison avec
philippe muray re bonjour monsieur vous
êtes économiste merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
merci beaucoup pour votre habitation
alors suivi demeurèrent selon les ong
oxfam la pandémie a bien entendu creuser
les inégalités particularité avec
l'arrivée du corona virus c'est la
première fois qu'elles ont augmenté
simultanément dans la quasi-totalité des
pays du monde et quel est concrètement
compte tenu de la situation sanitaire
actuelle
la marge de manoeuvre de la communauté
internationale pour freiner ces
inégalités communauté internationale
aucune parce que toute manière on pourra
en parler plus tard mais le problème
c'est la mondialisation économique qui
crée cette montée des inégalités aussi
et la financiarisation donc n'oublions
pas d'ailleurs que oxfam où on est une
ong mais oxfam états unis est financé
par des milliardaires américains par la
fondation rockefeller il suffit d'aller
sur internet sur leur page 2 qui les
financent donc en revanche moi ce qui
m'intéresse je suis un économiste
français c'est là on peut travailler en
france il ya une très forte montée quand
même des inégalités que le coronavirus
il y à un million de pauvres en plus on
est passé de 9 à 10 millions de pauvres
on a 20 % des français qui ne mangent
pas à leur faim selon les études les
derniers sondages je crois que c'était
le secours populaire
nous ne sommes pas en france on a
l'impression d'être dans en train de
passer dans un pays du tiers-monde 20
ports sont des gens qui ne mangent pas à
leur faim et on a un tiers qui renonce à
soigner faute d'argent
voilà on a des classes moyennes aussi
qu'ils sont des classements avec un
chômage qui monte de façon très
importante le taux de chômage est
annoncée à 8 % par l'insee est ce qui
est faux le taux de chômage de l'insee
c'est un sondage c'est pas du tout une
photographie du dur en fait moi j'estime
que le taux de chômage la population
active à près de 25% et on havrais les
classements ce que si vous perdez votre
job aujourd'hui
d'après les sources que j'ai en interne
à pôle emploi et d'autres gens on vous
re classe avec un salaire qui est à peu
près 20% inférieur à ce que vous aviez
avant sans problème donc on a un vrai
déclassement et enfin son d'aller
milliards d un je crois que vous le
disiez juste avant c'est que les
milliardaires en fait ont vu leur
fortune explosé mais ça date pas du kobe
danse c'est une politique de long terme
qui est une politique de mondialisation
économique
milliards d'euros de plus pour les
milliardaires américains on a aussi
depuis 2009 en fait les milliardaires
français dont la fortune est passé de 80
milliards à 450 milliards d'euros soit
cinq pour la fortune en disant c'est
absolument extraordinaire et c'est un
mag à nice qui vient de loin et pourquoi
le mécanisme il est tout simple c'est
qu'au lieu de relancer l'économie réelle
en europe on en est très loin puisque on
confine complètement les gens donc on va
pas relancer ont confiné ont continué à
détruire
mais au lieu de relancer l'économie
réelle on a un plan de relance européen
qui est absolument ridicule beaucoup
trop petit beaucoup de diffus étalé sur
trois ans par contre on a relancé la
finance et les marchés financiers la
spéculation
avec 2000 milliards d'euros de planche à
billets d'argent public et ça c'est un
scandale parce que ça fait monter les
cours de bourse ça fait monter
l'immobilier mais en revanche ça ne
donne pas d'argent au contraire aux
autres personnes ça nourrit des
milliardaires et les plus riches qui ont
des actifs alors que les autres sont
laissés à eux-mêmes à leurs fins leur
impossibilité de se soigner alors
chômage mais pour vous dire c'est pas
tout à fait des inégalités en fait le
vrai problème parce qu'en fait le taux
d' inégalités en france est pas si élevé
quand vous regardez le monde entier il
augmente mais ils n'augmentent pas tant
que ça le problème c'est la
paupérisation de la france la france est
engagée sur une voie
à mon avis qui est une voie de
tiers-mondisation voilà et qui est caché
par l' inflation artificielle des actifs
vous êtes d'accord avec ça la france est
engagée dans une voie de paupérisation
ben moi je vais même plus loin que
philippe puisque je suis en train de
faire les jeux en train de travailler
dessus en train de faire les calculs sur
le sur le chômage et on arrive on tutoie
les 10 millions entre le chômage et les
gens qui sont à temps partiel non voulue
c'est à dire non souhaitée plus ceux qui
sont au rsa on est on est quasiment à
deux millions de bénéficiaires du rsa
on est à un million et demi de 2
de gens qui travaillent à temps partiel
de façon non volontaire on est à huit
cent mille personnes qui sont
complètement sortis des radars c'est à
dire soit trois cent mille sdf et
d'autres qui sont qui ne touche pas le
rsa qui ne touche pas le chômage qui ne
sont pas inscrits et c'est donc on est
on est pas loin des 10 millions sachant
que vous avez une
une population active qui est de 29
millions un peu plus de 29 millions ça
fait un tiers ça fait ça fait trente 30
% de gens qui sont peau parce que quand
vous n'êtes quand vous êtes au chômage
et là ces chiffres là ne tiennent même
pas compte de ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
en chômage qu vite si vous voulez en
chaume en chômage partiel et qui vont se
transformer malheureusement une fois les
aides terminé en chômeurs tout court
et en plus vous avez eu un phénomène qui
s'est passé d'ailleurs pas que pas qu'en
france mais aussi aux états unis sec
on a quand même beaucoup poussé les gens
à devenir leur propre patron à devenir
entrepreneurs alors tout ça c'est très
bien quand ça fonctionne
le problème c'est quand ça fonctionne
pas généralement ils sont pas assurés
contre le chômage et donc ils sortent
directement des statistiques et en plus
ils deviennent pauvres tout de suite
puisqu'il touche rien et ils ne sont pas
aidés donc vous allez avoir les dépenses
une fois que les les choses vont se
calmer au niveau sanitaire et une fois
que les choses vont reprendre
alors soit on continue comme on le fait
jusqu'à maintenant et ce qui est la
solution d'ailleurs la plus probable est
à ce moment là on va camoufler encore
les chiffres pendant un moment ça irait
bien jusqu'aux élections je pense que
monsieur macron serais content de
pouvoir passer les élections avec des
chiffres encore pas trop mauvais mais si
vous rajoutez si vous arrêtez toutes ces
aides
vous allez avoir un effondrement de pas
mal de sociétés qui vont licencier et
vous avez une partie des chômeurs qui
aujourd'hui sont chômeurs à temps à
temps partiel avec les aides du
gouvernement qui vont se retrouver au
chômage tout court
quand vous partez déjà de 10 millions
vous imaginez ce que ça peut donner
on peut très vite monter à 40% de la
population active qui se retrouve son
boulot alors après ça va leur permettre
de nous fourguer le revenu universel ce
qu'il je pense ils ont dans la tête
depuis le début un messie on va marquer
une courte pause on revient dans un
instant
bienvenue dans ses cages si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine les
inégalités qui se creusent un peu plus
chaque jour en raison du court aux
navires us et pour cela nous sommes en
liaison avec philippe muray économistes
monsieur muraire si les pays
interviennent immédiatement pour réduire
les inégalités la pauvreté pourrait
redescendre à son niveau d'avant la
crise en trois ans contre plus de 10 ans
en action immédiate
autrement dit en 2030 on pourrait
compter 3 4 milliards de personnes
vivent avec moins de 5 dollars 50 par
jour c'est en tout cas ce qu'ont révélé
les calculs de la banque mondiale
comment intervenir selon vous comment
intervenir bien je crois que la clé
en fait de la prospérité parce qu'on a
vu que le problème n'est pas un problème
d'inégalité le problème un problème de
paupérisation et qui est due aux modèles
économiques cournac est très mauvaise et
d'un modèle économique mondialistes
niveau économique c'est la
mondialisation le cas de multi cressat
il ya un modèle de finances
donc c'est ça le problème donc le sujet
il est d'arrêter ex modèle économique
nous ce qu'on veut faire c'est l'arrêté
en france effectivement pour arrêter la
destruction parce que la cause de la
paupérisation de la france de la tiers
mondisation sûr avec la langue s'engage
c'est la destruction de l'industrie
française ça c'est fondamental en termes
d'économies je me réfère à en fait j'ai
trouvé il ya un an d'ailleurs une preuve
qui est vraiment très jolie de ce
problème là c'est claude sicard un
économiste qui a montré ça vous tracez
un graphique ou vous montrer d'un côté
vous mettez le pib par habitant donc la
richesse par habitant est de l'autre
côté de ce graphique vous mettez la
production industrielle par habitant et
vous rendez compte que vous êtes une
droite comme vous avez beaucoup
d'industries comme la suisse vous êtes
très riche deux fois plus qu'en france
quand vous avez deux très peu
d'industries comme l'un de vous est très
pauvre et quand vous êtes la france vous
êtes au milieu est en train de glisser
vers le bas avec l'industrie qui bat
kiki en train de baisser donc ce qui est
fondamental c'est de redresser
l'industrie en france il n'y a pas de
redressement de l'industrie
il n'y aura pas de hausse de la richesse
par habitant il n'y aura pas de
prospérité il n'y aura beaucoup
d'inégalités
c'est qu'est ce qui détruit notre
industrie c'est le système économique
mondialiste et c'est donc bien m
évidemment la cour à transmission du
mondialiste qui est l'européisme c'est
le robuste qui détruit cette industrie
alors justement olivier parmi les
préconisations à d'oxfam proscrire les
mesures d'austérité brutale et non
durable et créer je cite une économie
juste et inclusive qui promeut l'égalité
préserve la planète et éradiquer la
pauvreté ça ressemble à quoi
concrètement une économie justes et
inclusives olivier sens récente la sueur
des mots qui ne veulent rien dire ce
genre d'organisme est est assez
professionnel là dedans non le comme le
dit philippe il faut il faut il faudrait
réindustrialiser le seul problème qu'on
va avoir c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a perdu
des compétences là dedans on a perdu un
savoir faire et que ça va être très
compliqué de réindustrialiser comme ça
réindustrialiser c'est pas juste en
claquant des doigts vous faites revenir
les sociétés d'abord il faut changer
complètement tout c'est à dire tout ce
qui les a fait partir tout ce qui a été
le les causes de leur départ si vous
voulez changer pas elle n'a aucune
raison de revenir les sociétés donc et
elles resteront bien tranquille dans
d'autres dans d'autres pays hélas
aujourd'hui on n'en prend pas le chemin
tout simplement c'est à dire qu'on est
on est toujours dans cette
dans cette optique non pas d'austérité
d'ailleurs il parle d'austérité moi j'ai
pas vu d'austérité nulle part il n'y a
pas d'austérité il ya débauche d'argent
qu'on met sur le sur la table sans se
préoccuper de savoir qui au final va
payer parce que c'est ce que je vous
disais dans le lancement des missions au
final c'est toujours les mêmes les
dindons de la farce c'est toujours les
mêmes vers qui on va se tourner pour
aller payer la note donc
vous avez aujourd'hui des dépenses
inconsidérées absolument aucune question
sur de l'austérité jeu pas si vous avez
vu de l'austérité quelque part si
l'austérité c'est de fermer tout c'est
de fermer toute l'économie
monsieur merrer parmi les autres pistes
selon le center ni international
coopération 71 % des européens serait
temps faveur d'un revenu universel de
base autre opinion au royaume uni à
présent selon le think tank surveille
70% des britanniques serait favorable à
un plafonnement des rémunérations à cent
mille deux cent mille ou encore 300
mille livres par an est ce que ce genre
de mesures pourrait selon vous être
efficace pour pour arrêter ces
inégalités et stopper justement la
paupérisation dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure
bah c'est pas stoppé la paupérisation si
enlever la dignité aux gens le revenu
universel c'est dire vous servez à rien
on tient on te donne 700 euros tétouan
il va à la niche chez toi et tu n'as
plus aucune utilité sociale
non ça révèle la faillite de gens parce
que quel est le meilleur moyen de tuer
quelqu'un sinon de le payer à rien faire
vous avez payé à rien faire pendant un
an deux ans trois ans dix ans et après
on va faire quoi des gens qui pendant
dix ans n'ont pas pu travailler parce
que le rendit on s'en fout que le modèle
économique ne crée pas d'emplois vous
servez à rien vous comprenez ce sont des
monstres ces gens là effectivement et de
penser ça en plus on a besoin de ces
gens là bas on à toute personne a une
utilité sociale
donc il faut arrêter de plaisanter le
revenu universel c'est une fac
une façon de tuer les gens après
derrière il y aura ceux qui vont payer
qui travailleront qui sont très fâchés
de voir qu'il y en a des gens qui
accompagnent pour ne pas travailler
c'est une façon d'exploser la société il
ne faut absolument pas prendre de revenu
universel qu'on est quand sévèrement les
gens oui et concernant le plafonnement
des rémunérations par exemple mais c'est
complètement stupide sas et c'est en
fait ces instituts multinationales
disent n'importe quoi
comment voulez moi je serais pour un
plafonnement de raismes de rémunérations
des patrons
mais est ce que vous pensez qu'on va
arriver que tous les pays du monde
arrive à plafonner les rémunérations en
même temps donc ça c'est des petites
choses qui sont envoyées comme sac mais
qui servent absolument à rien
oui ça serait une bonne chose mais ça
sera jamais trop lié mais c'est très
démagogue et puis c'est ça veut surtout
rien dire plafonner les plafonner les
salaires des patrons et espérons
dividende aujourd'hui c'est pas celui
qui gagne sans milou 200 milles qui qui
a augmenté sa fortune
c'est ces lots musk d'accord sans vendre
une seule voiture d'ailleurs mais ça
c'est un autre problème mais c'est lui
qui a augmenté son son sa fortune et sa
fortune aujourd'hui c'est ses titres en
bourse c'est pas son salaire il s'en
fiche complètement de son salaire donc
il se perd à des dividendes ou il vendra
quelques actions donc on n'est pas ça
veut rien dire c'est juste démagogique
le gars qui gagne aujourd'hui au royaume
uni cent mille euros par part en c'est
pas c'est pas quelqu'un qui est riche
c'est pas quelqu'un qui est riche c'est
quelqu'un simplement qui est de la
classe moyenne si vous voulez donc ce
que je vous disais c'est toujours la
classe moyenne qui va payer
le leu a vu le en plus les prix de
l'immobilier à londres et autres je peux
vous dire qu'avec 100 mille balles vous
n'êtes pas prêt de vous loger et de et
de vivre correctement donc ça n'est pas
et le musk et ceux qui sont enrichis
aujourd'hui grâce à au quantitative
easing des banques centrales
c'est pas c'est pas le gars qui gagnent
100 mille balles c'est ces lots d'oeufs
musk c'est bernard arnault
c'est jeff bezos c est donc c'est tout à
fait démagogique d'aller viser celui qui
gagne
sa vie alors après on peut bien sûr
monsieur hollande vous dirais qu'au
dessus de 4000 balle par mois c'est vous
êtes riche
ok on est d'accord je n'ose pas me
demander combien ils gagnent par mois
lui à ne rien faire mais pourquoi pas
messieurs vaquero par mois si je me
permets 4000 euros par mois tu
effectivement en france on fait partie
des 10% les plus riches il ya 8000 euros
par mois on fait partie des 1% les plus
riches ce qui montre qu'effectivement
woogie niro mois par mois on a trois
bien vivre mais ce qui montre quand même
qu'à une paupérisation très claire de la
france quoi monsieur meira pour terminer
en france un mot sur cette proposition
de l'ex patron de la sncf louis gallois
c'était le 22 février chez nos confrères
de europe 1 il propose d'introduire je
cite un impôt de solidarité sur le
revenu est des plus aisés pendant une
période bien définie
deux ans par exemple un objectif venir
en aide aux plus démunis
louis gallois qui a aussi précisé que
cet impôt ne serait pas pour but de
financer la dette publique alors faire
payer les riches en en temps de crise
c'est tentant pour autant est-ce que
l'on peut vraiment s'attendre au
ruissellement
la première chose on va faire payer les
riches qui sont sur le sol français
c'est-à-dire les moyennement riches qui
ont entre quatre et huit mille euros par
mois et tous les très riches eux ils ont
le seul argent au luxembourg l'enquète
du monde la montre et ils ont des
filiales partout au luxembourg et ils
sont très mini de ça déjà ça pose un
problème majeur ça paye et faire payer
les classes moyennes supérieures et par
les très riches vraiment et puis le
problème il n'est pas de se battre de
prendre à paul pour habiller jacques ou
de prendre à jacques pour habiller paul
le problème n est pas là le problème il
est de relancer maintenant qu'ils
reconnaissent que leur système
mondialiste avec le libre-échange
partout avec l'euro est une catastrophe
économique
la france est rien à des pays qui a la
plus faible croissance du monde très
longue période avec l'italie et
l'espagne que tout cela c'est une
catastrophe et changer de modèle
économique
voilà de changer de modèle économique
pour créer des emplois pour créer des
emplois industriels à forte valeur
ajoutée
ce pays en est capable regardez la
france a été capable de faire le rafale
avion de chasse de dernière génération
les états unis
vienne d'acter que le f-35 est une
catastrophe et ne marche pas le
pentagone vient de l'acte et donc vous
voyez on est capable c'est les français
sont des gens absolument capables de
faire du travail qui est de très bonne
qualité même si on a un problème avec
l'école aujourd'hui
mais voilà il faut leur laisser les
moyens il faut les aider à faire ça au
lieu de les mettre dans un modèle
économique qui détruit leur industrie
qui détruit leur économie c'est ça le
sujet merci beaucoup philippe maurer
d'avoir été parmi nous dans cette
émission je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste olivier nous on passe aux
questions cash et on recommence tout de
suite olivier avec la question de trivy
en cas de crash des marchés boursiers
avec des titres qui reviennent à des
valeurs indexés sur du réel le risque
n'est-il pas simplement que les plus
riches perdre ce qu'ils détiennent alors
ils perdront une partie de ce qu'ils
détiennent
maintenant maintenant ça a tellement été
gonflé par par les différents
quantitative easing que il en restera
quand même quelque chose en plus
ne vous faites aucune illusion ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire aujourd'hui c'est
à dire vous avez vu qu'ils manipulent
les marchés ils manipulent les marchés
du du beacon y manipule les marchés sur
certaines valeurs
croyez bien que ils font de l'argent
c'est à dire que il vous utilisent ils
utilisent les petits porteurs ceux qui
viennent d'arriver en bourse pour leur
refiler au plus haut ce qu'ils ont
acheté beaucoup plus bas donc ne vous
fait absolument pas de souci pour eux
ils sont en train de faire beaucoup
d'argent sur votre dos non mais à
présent on passe à présent olivia la
question de jack atkine quelqu'un peut
m'expliquer le cannibalisme financier
s'il vous plaît quand ils rachètent
leurs actions en empruntant pour les
détruire comptablement aussi tout simple
si vous voulez c'est à dire que vous
avez quelque chose en bourse qui sert à
évaluer une action qui s'appelle le
bénéfice par action donc comprend le
bénéfice global on le divise par le
nombre d'actions et on obtient le
bénéfice par action etc saissac ce que
qu'on vend si vous voulez qu'on vend ou
aux investisseurs en disant voilà il ya
une croissance de bon mon bénéfice par
action alors comment faire de la
croissance quand y en a plus en fait
quand votre résultat stagne ou voir est
en baisse c'est tout simple vous
réduisez le nombre d'actions
si vous réduisez ce qui a en bas de
votre division et bien vous de vous fait
grossir le chiffre est donc si quelque
chose est divisé par 100 et puis que ça
devient / 10 évidemment ça fait ça fait
plus et ils vous vendent ça
et en vous disant regardez on a fait de
la croissance de résultats mais si vous
regardez ce qui se passe depuis déjà une
ou plusieurs années aux états unis avec
ce système là on a des résultats qui
stagne en fait en masse en volume
on a des résultats qui stagne et on a
des bénéfices par actions qui sont en
très forte hausse
et pourquoi parce que les les
différentes sociétés rachètent leurs
propres titres les annuler et comme ça
arrive à faire croître ce qui n'est pas
ce qui n'est pas en croissance alors ce
qu'il ya d'intéressant là dedans c'est
pourquoi le font-ils
pourquoi le font-ils pas tout simplement
parce que généralement les salaires des
patrons de ces boîtes là sont indexés
sur quoi pas sur les performances
économiques de la société
comme toujours le même exemple monsieur
elon musk mais en revanche sur les
performances boursières et donc il a
tout intérêt à ce que son titre monte
parce que c'est ça qui l'enrichît c'est
pas les performances économiques
il peut vendre trois voitures par an
c'est pas grave du moment que son titre
monte est là aujourd'hui on assiste à ça
et on assiste à ça depuis d'ailleurs
plusieurs années où vous avez en gros à
peu près 1 trion c'est à dire mille
milliards de dollars de rachats de
titres par an donc c'est l'équivalent si
vous voulez d'un quantitative easing
donc il faut pas s'étonner que les
bourses montent puisque on réduit sans
arrêt le nombre de titres en bourse pour
que les les cours montent donc voilà ce
que c'est que le cannibalisme financiers
merci beaucoup olivier c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain rendez vous la semaine
prochaine en attendant n'oubliez pas de
poser à toutes vos questions à olivier
sur les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag
rta cacher puis pour voir nos
précédentes émissions ça se passe sur
notre site internet à l'adresse rt
france point tv olivier c'est à vous
pour le monde de la f1
alors ne vous trompez pas le coc vie
n'est qu'un prétexte un prétexte à
réduire nos libertés un prétexte à nous
appauvrir
et un prétexte à ce que vous soyez
toujours et encore le dindon de la farce